a menos de 5 meses de las elecciones ya
son 5 los precandidatos a la presidencia
bajo arresto en nicaragua algo que desde
la oposición califican como una
persecución política que lleva en marcha
en los últimos tres años el régimen ha
estado secuestrando a personas durante
los últimos tres años lo que pasa que en
estas últimas tres semanas lo que ha
hecho el régimen es que ha secuestrado a
los candidatos y candidatas que son a la
presidencia el periodista miguel mora es
el más reciente fue detenido por atentar
contra la soberanía nacional junto a
arturo cruz sebastián chamorro félix
maradiaga y cristiana chamorro la
principal rival de daniel ortega y quien
podría hacer peligrar la tercera
reelección del sandinista hay un gran
temor de la salud y la condición física
mental y psicológica de estos candidatos
hay candidatos que tienen problemas de
presión arterial que tienen diabetes que
tienen otra índole y no sabemos bajo qué
condiciones está porque el régimen no
permite que se vean a los precandidatos
además en
marco de una polémica ley que el
ejecutivo aprobó en diciembre del 2020
también han sido detenidos otros líderes
opositores como ex cancilleres ex
guerrilleros empresarios y activistas
hechos condenados por la comunidad
internacional y por lo que argentina y
méjico llamaron a consultas a sus
respectivos embajadores no obstante
ambas naciones siguen apostando por la
no intervención en asuntos internos
razón por la que se abstuvieron de votar
en la resolución de la oea contra las
acciones del gobierno de ortega